I do have to ask you about you know the
biggest rumor out there about you
wanting to buy majority States in bet
rumor no that's not a rumor it's not a
rumor it's not a rumor no I I've been
there for
four years now and have tremendous
success and I wasn't expecting this to
happen so yes I'm very if that is
possible I am very very interested in
taking much as much of it as I can are
there conversations is it possible if
it's possible I'm going to take a threat
as much of it as I can why would
something like that be so important to
you you know part of it is I you know
I've read about Byron Allen and puffy
and everybody you know wanting to bid
and so on and so forth and I think it's
really great because when this is what I
love about it when Bob Johnson sold it
uh in 2000 I think it was there wasn't
one black person who could buy it so now
to see all of these black people men and
women who were able to to be in a
position to buy it that sound man that
makes me feel really really excited like
you said there's so many
um people of color who say you know what
this network means something to the
culture means something to us
um and having ownership
yeah yeah I think there was sadness when
Bob sold it and I think there'll be a
lot of Happiness when when it's black
owned again and even though Shari and
and when the surviacom and Fairmont
they've done a phenomenal job with it
and they didn't let it fall by the
wayside they didn't let it go into dust
they nurtured it and took care of it and
and to see Shari at this position saying
I think it should be returned yes to a
black owner I'm thinking okay see that's
that's my kind of person and everything
could align everything could align yeah
for sure is there like a time frame when
you think people you know there could be
a resolution sure yeah there's a time
frame when there could be a resolution
yes
this could be later rather than sooner
or later or yesterday but today tomorrow
next month next year six years well I
like to know that there is genuine
interest on your part there are
conversations happening on your part and
there can be a resolution we can very
much say that there are conversations
I'm beyond interested and there will be
a resolution
in
22 years
thank you